2013 has officially become the year in
which we adapt fables into movies and
take them seriously Hansel and Gretel
mm-hmm
Jack and the giant slayer jack and the
giant slayer is directed by bryan singer
and it stars nicholas hoult ian mcshane
Ewan McGregor and Stanley Tucci as well
as some other people this is a twisting
around of the fable of Jack and the
Beanstalk you know giant Beanstalk grows
up and Jack climbed it and all that
stuff went down in this movie there's a
princess that he has a thing for she
gets caught up in this Beanstalk that
goes all the way up into the heavens and
up there is where the Giants live in the
Giants hate humans and the humans hate
the Giants and now suddenly this
Beanstalk has a way of branching these
two lands together when the princess
gets trapped up in that land where the
Giants are Jack you and McGregor and
some other of the Kings finest men have
to go up there and try to save her now a
lot of people saw this trailer and
myself included and just kind of went
yeah the trailer just was not impressive
the visuals didn't look very good they
all looked very fake and it just didn't
really look that great it was a very
matte railer so going into this movie I
wasn't sure what I was going to
experience I liked Nicholas Hoult as an
actor and he does do a very good job in
this movie he was good in warm bodies
movie isn't bad at all it's just all
right there really isn't anything about
the movie that stands out as amazing the
performances are all good the movie is
directed very well it has a nice flow to
it the visuals do not look very good
though special effects are very
unrealistic the whole movie just feels
like yes I'm definitely looking at a CGI
giant right now I never actually got
that moment where I was invested in the
movie in which I felt yes those things
are real and I didn't think they were
very good looking and so it took me out
of the movie basically every time a
giant was on the movie I was like yeah
that's that's totally fake I've seen way
better special effects in movies that
are 10 years old like the Lord of the
Rings films for instance but it is still
a well made movie in an enjoyable time
and it is a fun adventure and there were
a lot of scenes in this movie that kept
my attention it wasn't the type of movie
that you go and you watch and you're
like oh man like I can't wait to tell
everyone about this movie and I can't
wait for everyone to see this movie it
wasn't like that type of adventure where
really sucks you into the movie and you
just feel like yes that was a really fun
experience it just didn't really have
that feel that you needed in the
characters it didn't have that pool
where you wanted to really care about
the characters in this movie and that's
largely the scripts fault you and regret
is a really likable actor he's actually
one of my favorite actors and while his
character has some entertaining moments
I really don't know a thing about him
like I couldn't latch onto his character
at all
he was so thinly drawn in this film and
really everyone is that cliched
adventure fable character like the poor
farm boy and the princess who doesn't
want to get married to the guy that
wants to get married to her she would
rather just make her own decisions
it is very well made though and so for
that reason I had a mostly fun time
watching this movie I can't really just
be like go out and see it because it has
a lot of issues mainly the visuals and
the characters not being very good at
all but it is still a well-made film
with entertaining performances and so I
can recommend perhaps renting it when it
comes out it has good set pieces it has
moments in which you go well that was
actually really cool it has some good
suspense as a great score by John
Otteman that's definitely one of the
biggest pluses of this movie the score
is very good and I'm not going to give
this movie a negative great because it's
not a bad movie it's just alright and
there's not that much to talk about this
you can't really latch on to like a meat
of this movie it really just feels kind
of like a retread of other adventures
that were more well told this does have
some pretty fun sequences though and all
the best sequences of this movie
generally the ones without a ton of CGI
in them whenever the CGI is sort of
lording over the sequences you can just
really tell that it's not real so I'm
going to give Jack in the giant slayer
of B - I think it'd be a really nice
rental if you have a group of friends
over you just want to have something on
to keep you guys entertained you might
enjoy it it was a nice try but it could
have been a little bit better thanks a
lot for watching guys and as always if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes